okay today we are really changing the
game we're doing something Innovative
and different uh we're gonna do a video
you've never seen a video like this
before I had this idea where we do a
video where I answered the internet's
most searched questions about me it's
never been done before and the thing I
like about it is that it's not in the
least bit narcissistic or
self-referential at all I also like to
think it's a chance to clear up some
misinformation because when you're
famous in other words you there's a lot
of wrong information about you on there
so every day you go on the internet and
you find another fact about you that
isn't correct so this is a chance to
clear all that up and I think it's going
to be a handy sort of reference for
people who are wondering about any
biographical information about me they
can just go to this video and here it is
for you laid out
uh in a handy way
[Music]
okay is Matt Walsh married
uh I am married I've been married to my
lovely wife Gertrude for 46 years we
live in Ohio and we have two parents
and an iguana
recently passed away
is Matt Walsh in Ted
who is Ted
anyway no I'm straight
is Matt Walsh in Elf oh the movie Elf
okay so I see what we're doing here we
are getting questions for me and for the
other Matt Walsh because there's a
there's a second Matt Walsh out there
actually and uh so I guess we're gonna
get some of his questions too
and you know something interesting has
happened because when I first came on
the scene the other Matt Walsh was like
the way more famous Matt Walsh and so if
you want to Google all the Matt Walsh
information was about that Matt Walsh
and now it's kind of flipped and I think
I've sort of uh
subsumed I've I've all I've I've
absorbed all the other Matt Walsh's
doesn't even sound right I just said I
was straight so anyway is Matt Walsh and
elf uh the movie Elf yes I I was I
played one of the reindeer so motion
capture performance is Matt Walsh
documentary on Netflix
uh it is Netflix offered me 85
million dollars for it and of course I
accepted is Matt Walsh Catholic I'm
actually an adherent to the uh vadriana
School of Buddhism
which is a thing I think now we move
over to does Matt Walsh prompts what
does the internet ask does Matt Walsh
does Matt Walsh homeschool
I actually send all of my kids to a
boarding school in Brazil I haven't seen
them in three years
agree
do I'm a big proponent of a higher
education I have a bachelor's in
feminist Theory and I have a PhD in
applied physics
which is a pretty standard combo classic
combination as they say does Matt Walsh
have a high school diploma I do not I
dropped out in first grade and I don't
know how to read
does Matt Walsh play the banjo
um I do that's and we actually have a
video you can check of me teaching a
famous musician how to play the banjo
does Matt Walsh Matt Welsh's wife work
um yes she is uh it is much to my urging
I said please get out of the house and
get a job contribute and she became a
bus driver in Portland
I haven't seen her in three years
does Matt Walsh have a dog I have five
dogs actually I call them my fur babies
and they're kind of my children so I
refer to them and I'm a big animal lover
and it's the first thing people think
about me think of you know think of when
they think of me I think does Matt Walsh
have a tattoo no I I don't believe them
um what is Matt Walsh's tattoo I have in
fact a
stamp of
the character Alf on my lower back
I'm just ruined his entire video what is
Matt Walsh's net worth well I invested
all of my money last year in nfts of
those uh of those monkey of the monkey
nfts and someone told me it's a great
investing opportunity
to put all your money into the monkey
cards and I said sounds good to me my
net worth is now 32 dollars
what is Matt Walsh's IQ well I just this
one I just had checked at one of those
machines at CVS
and uh it was 120 over 70 which I was
told is right in the right range for my
age and weight when you use the bathroom
you always close the door behind you I I
would hope right well you don't want
random passers by to look in on you so
why would you let people look in on what
you're doing when you go online did you
know that your internet service provider
knows every single website you visit
what's worse is they can sell this
information to ad companies and Tech
Giants who will use your data to Target
you expressvpn puts a stop to all of
this it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone I use expressvpn
on all my devices it works on everything
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your Wi-Fi can still be
protected even if they don't have
expressvpn best part is using expressvpn
is as easy as closing the bathroom door
you just fire up the app click one
button and you're protected it's as
simple as that so if you're like me and
you believe that your online activity is
your business visit expressvpn.com Walsh
YT and get three extra months free
expressvpn.com Walsh why T to learn more
what is Matt Walsh's occupation I am a
Peloton instructor believe it or not
life is all about choices and those
bangs that you just got well that was a
choice what is Matt Walsh's email
address well this is kind of personal uh
it's a little bit embarrassing I've had
the same email address since I was 14
and so and so just keep in mind that's
where it's from when I was 14 but it is
Backstreet Boy fan 87 at aol.com
what is Matt Walsh's real name my real
name is uh Richard
Bumble uh bumblebee Richard
bumblebee is my name why is Matt Walsh
called Sweet Daddy these are just kind
of miscellaneous questions well we don't
answer that question you know whoever
asked it will have their IP address
tracked and they will be killed in their
sleep
was Matt Walsh in parks and rec uh I was
yes guilty's charged what band was Matt
Walsh in I uh briefly
played the recorder in the band Smash
Mouth
[Music]
this was from 2001 to 2003.
it's a lot of good information uh
how old is Matt Walsh from the daily
wire um
you know it's spiritually I just turned
93 last month so those are the questions
now we do have some internet facts we
have some facts that uh you'll find
about me on so if you go and you look up
those questions before I just gave you
the real information uh there are like
websites that will give you what they
claim are the the correct information
about Matt Walsh and I guess I kind of
ruined this last part of the video
because the funny thing with the
internet facts is that they aren't true
but then I just said a bunch of
so I trampled over that punch line by
not seriously answering any of the
questions so are we even still going to
do this I guess so
[Music]
uh Matt Walsh's net worth is nine
million US dollars
correct
Matt Walsh owns nine luxury watches
also correct Matt Walsh has lost half of
his portfolio through trading and stocks
in the past five years he has lost over
1.6 million dollars in stock markets and
500 000 more in crypto this is very
specific this is more specific false
information than I thought it's actually
not false that that part is true too
Matt Walsh spends most of his wealth on
luxury watches parties and travel
again guilty as charged in the past year
he spent four hundred and ten thousand
dollars very specific number on partying
how would they claim to know that so
they know what do you mean on partying
it's like a broad category of things to
spend your money on and they know the
exact dollar amount and seven hundred
thousand dollars more on watches and
designer clothes Walsh is also a
frequent buyer of luxury cars he owns a
Ferrari and a McLaren
I don't know how they know this I don't
know how they're getting this
information but it's all true uh Matt
Walsh owns a three-bedroom apartment in
Nashville Tennessee Walsh has bought his
property for four four hundred eighty
thousand dollars from a republican donor
Walsh also owns two other properties in
Texas which is true and Matt Wilson's
primary income source is the fee he
charges for hosting shows and appearing
on radio shows you know yeah those if
you go on terrestrial radio
a lot of money in that industry because
it's not collapsing at all and uh
they'll pay you huge money
anytime you hear someone doing an
interview on like the you know am 620
as you're driving down the road that is
someone getting paid Millions for that
Matt Walsh's home address I don't even
know I can read this
they have my home address the 6017
Cirrus Street San Diego
92110 I feel sorry for whoever lives
there
because it's me so to review I am a 93
year old man from Ohio named Richard
bumblebee I own five dogs two parrots
and a dead iguana I have a stamp
of an 80 80s television character uh I'm
illiterate but I have a PhD in physics I
lost all my savings uh in from nfts I
played the recorder in Smash Mouth I
have a net worth of nine million dollars
which I earned from fees from appearing
on AM radio I own a McLaren and a
Ferrari and I live in a modest
three-bedroom apartment that was
purchased for me by a republican donor
in Nashville Tennessee
that about sums it up
thanks for watching
foreign